- France Talbot et Jean-Marc
aguerris.
- C'est un mode de vie.
- Au moins 50 ans, et plus!
- Ah oui! Ça fait 50 ans et
plus, là, t'sais.
observent beaucoup de nouveaux
amateurs de plein air.
en espadrille. Puis, vraiment
des petites espadrilles.
- Je dirais que depuis
la pandéas comment se préparer.
- Mais une mauvaise préparation
peut entraîner de mauvaises
surprises, même chez les plus
expérimentés.
- En 2020, on est parti
quatre personnes au mont Groulx,
avec ma blonde, puis deux amis,
à leur première grosse
expédition. La quatrième
journée, il s'est mis
à avoir un blizzard, puis
il y a eu 20 cm de neige durant
la journla journla journée. Nos,
leur bottes n'étaient pas
adéquates pour le climat.
- Après 14 heures d'attente,
ils ont été secourus
par l'armée canadienne.
- On se sent vulnérable
dans l'attente.
- Et même sur les sentiers
bien balisés...er.
éduc., Parc national Mont-Orford
- Donc, c'est au niveauiveauiveu
de la planification de
leur visite que qui aurait
de l'amélioration à faire.
Ils n'auront pas regardé
les cartes avant de venir.
Ils n'aulanifié
leur itinéraire. Des fois,
ils peuvent arriver mal
chaussés. Ils arrivent
avec pasau.
- Les premiers répondants
notent une hausse des appels
de détresse.
ESMARAIS, capitaine,
serv. incendies Cantons d'Orford
- L'équation est facile à faire;
plus de randonneurs, plus
d'incidents, plus de sorties.
- Ces sorties impliquentbeaucou.
Neuf pompiers sont nécessaires
pour transporter ce panier
en montagne.
- Avec une ascension d'environ
600 m, bien ça peut nous prendre
jusqu'à 2 heures, 2,5 heures.
On a déjà vu jusqu'à 3 heures
juste pour atteindre la victime.
(bruit de rotors)
- À l'échelle de la province,
les appels à la Sureté
du Québec pour des opérations
de recherche-sauvetages ont
aussi augmenté. 361 appels
en 2021; une hausse de 40 %
par rapport à 2018.
Les opérations de sauvetage
restent tout de même minimessurs
chaque année.
La randonnée demeure une
activité sûre et accessible.
t de bien s'équiper.
Ici Marie Isabelle Rochon,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.